we can speak to the shadow work and
pension secretary Jonathan Ashworth who
is talking to us from Central London and
good to have you on the program this
morning so do you back the government's
plan on small boats
well we've not seen the actual
legislation we'll study it carefully
we'll want to see whether there are
clear plans to tackle the The Gangs who
are smuggling people illegally across
the channel and put completely abusing
people we're told in the past that
they've got plans and legislation that
was going to deal with this problem and
their promises came to nothing and
actually we've seen more Boat Crossings
and the criminal gangs getting away with
more and more so we'll study it
carefully we'll also look to see whether
this will actually deal with the backlog
in a processing Asylum cases and it's of
course because of that huge backlog that
the criminal gangs are either are able
to exploit the situation now the
government have been in power now for 12
13 years they've allowed this backlog to
build up so we'll look at it carefully
we'll see if it actually practically
deals with the existing problems in the
system but I have to say we have heard
these promises before from conservative
politicians
you're absolutely right of course to
highlight the huge backlog in processing
Asylum claims which has a big knock-on
effect but just in principle Chris
Heaton Harris said that it's gonna be
black and white very simple very clear
do you support the idea uh that it
should you should be banned from
claiming asylum in the UK if you enter
here illegally
well again we've not seen the actual
legislation we see conservative
ministers making big promises all the
time together
if I may just to come in if I may
because I I do understand that you
haven't seen the legislation you want to
have a look at the detail but I'm just
asking you about the broad principle
well the broad principle is that
refugees who arrive in this country we
have always welcomed them peoples whose
Asylum applications have been turned
down then of course they should be
returned that is a principle that we
have always accepted the problem is of
course the conservatives will come out
here and they will get headlines and
they will and they will say they're
going to do this that and the other but
they never deliver do they we were told
last year that their uh their borders
bill was going to deal with this it
didn't so we will study it carefully but
we'll also want to see whether they're
going to crack down on those illegal
people smuggling gangs whether they're
going to deal with the Asylum backlog
because so far they have manifestly
failed on that front
but you say uh the Labor's position is
that refugees should be welcomed and of
course many people who come to the UK on
small boats are doing so because they're
desperate right they are fleeing
persecution there may not be any other
way for them to get to the UK and to put
in an asylum claim many of those claims
are then granted so if you do hold that
position that refugees are welcome
surely you should be opposing this plan
right but people they should be safe
routes for refugees the country opened
its doors up to people from Ukraine from
Afghanistan for example but where people
traffickers are exploiting this system
and people's Asylum case is uh turned
down then these people obviously have to
be returned now the government keep
telling us they're going to deal with
this problem but they never do so we'll
study the details of this bill when we
actually see it and we'll test it we'll
hold it to hold the government to
account but I've got to say hey they
keep making these promises they've been
making these promises for 18 months two
years or so and they never deliver
what's Labor's plan
well vet Cooper has outlined a plan we
would invest in a proper crime agency to
really to really crack down on these
people smuggling gangs we will deal with
the backlog in Asylum claims because
that backlog where people can go for
months and months and months and months
and months uh sometimes Beyond 12 months
uh that the the the gangs are exploiting
that aren't they so we outlined a plan
to deal with the problems in the system
and we will test this legislation on
whether we believe it will deal with the
actual problems that we've been
highlighting okay
um I want to talk to you a little bit
about um Sue gray
um the very heart of the Civil Service
is its reputation for impartiality for
serving and working for the government
of the day whoever it is elected by the
British people
I think it looks when a very senior
civil servant quits to become chief of
staff for the leader of the labor party
well Sue gray is a woman of exceptional
Talent abilities incredibly High Caliber
and in the same way in which senior
business people are now supporting the
labor party in the same way we have a
new crop of candidates of High Caliber I
think it shows how seriously people are
taking the prospect of kirst armor as
prime minister under labor government
and in turn in making this appointment I
think it reveals how seriously cursed
armor is taking our preparations for
government should the British people put
their trust in us at the next general
election she's a woman of immense
integrity and I'm I am delighted she's
uh hopefully coming to work for the
labor party
I guess my question is more about the
impression that it gives particularly
for those people who may believe rightly
or wrongly that the civil service is
effectively biased against the
conservative party in addition the
Privileges committee is looking into
Boris Johnson whether he misled
Parliament over partygate Sue gray of
course was the person who presided over
that inquiry has labor just handed Boris
Johnson and his allies the best ever get
out of jail free card they're already
saying that look you can't trust
anything that anyone says on partygate
because it was all a political smear
look so great she's now working for
labor
no not remotely remember Boris Johnson
said that Sue Gray's report validated
him and in fact the committee looking
into Boris Johnson's rule breaking at
the time when his conservative
government had put the country into
lockdown was a committee set up
unanimously by the whole of the House of
Commons has a majority of conservative
members of parliament on that committee
and has taken witness statements under
oath has relied on WhatsApp messages on
emails from Witnesses actually it's not
reliant on the Sue gray report because
she wasn't a witness to these parties it
was staffed in number 10. many of whom
have I said given evidence to this
committee and this committee found out
on or reported on Friday that the Belize
there is a case that Boris Johnson May
well have misled Parliament so I know
Boris Johnson's been on the TV sort of
trying to say that look this uh brings
the committee into question it most
certainly doesn't we've seen the photo
toes they're not photoshopped Boris
Johnson is there breaking the rules when
he put the country into lockdown
okay well we'll we'll find out what the
Privileges committee has to say uh later
on uh of course I'm really interested to
get your view as well on the other store
that's been dominating at the news for
the last couple of weeks Matt Hancock's
WhatsApp messages while he was Health
sector of course during the covid-19
pandemic you were shadowing him at the
time and I think in the Sunday Telegraph
today we can see that he says he wanted
to frighten the pants with the public
with the Kent they're in to try and
improve compliance with the legislation
rules what's your reaction to seeing all
of this play out
I mean I think so many of these messages
are
so troubling aren't they and I think in
the end it reinforces the case for a
proper full inquiry and we've got to get
they've it's got to get on we've got to
get on with this public inquiry I mean
other countries have completed their
inquiry we need at least some form of
preliminary report by the end of the
year all of this material has to be
handed over and I hope Rishi sunak is
insisting that all of this material from
any minister is handed over uh
in completely and I hope non ministers
are deleting whatsapps or anything of
that nature I think it also reveals that
or confirms that many of the concerns
that we raise throughout the pandemic
the failure to put a protective ring
around Care Homes the concerns that we
had in Leicester where we were in a
longer lockdown that that it turns out
that Rishi sunak's policies were
actually helping spread the virus which
kept us in Leicester and people in bury
and Bolton and Bradford in longer
lockdowns because of Wishy soon up it
confirms that there's a whole host of
mistakes were made that we were raising
at the time so we really do need a full
inquiry and the inquiry we need to get
on with it Rishi soon actually get a
grip of this and insist that we have
some form of report by the end of the
year you say that you're hoping
conservative ministers aren't deleting
their own whatsapps how about your
whatsapps if anything incriminating in
those would you be happy to hand them
over
but obviously if anybody wanted me to
cooperate with an inquiry of course of
course I would but I wasn't making
decisions
have you got any with Matt Hancock I
have Matt Hancock did WhatsApp me from
time to time but nothing as uh as um
interesting as what we've seen so far
I'm afraid anything you want to get out
before it appears in the telegraph
no no okay I don't think there's
anything interesting there
all right thank you uh very much indeed
Jonathan Ashworth uh speaking to us
there